Faut-il la compatibilité entre le donneur et le receveur, du point de vue de son sang, du groupe
ou alors même qui est en partie complète mais..
je vais reposer la question est-ce qu'il faut
une compatibilité entre le donneur et le receveur
On a eu il y à quelques années une conférence d'un biologiste
qui étudiait les vers et les arénicole. Et qui disait que l'hémoglobine des arénicoles
était particulièrement concentré et serait très utile
pour assurer la conservation des greffons et il
était en attente d'un brevet..
Donc merci pour votre question d'actualité très pertinente
Vous faites allusion aux travaux de Franck Zal
Voilà qui estvenu faire une conférence dans le cadre des mardis de l'Espace des sciences
Et qui travail effectivement sur
une hémoglobine de vers marins qui est capable de
fixer énormément d'oxygène et donc qui pourrait
être une solution pour cette fameuse durée d'ischémie
dont vous a parlé le docteur Rayar et moi-même.
Je suis infirmière anesthésiste et ce que je voulais dire c'est
Peut être dans l'information, expliquer aux gens que quand
on est donneur c'est une interventionchirurgicale
Les gens ils ont l'impression qu'on va tout ouvrir et que.. C'est comme ça. En fait on fait la même intervention quand on prélève et quand on donne.
Alors on va rappeler ce qu'a dit madame
Oui tout à fait, vous avez tout à fait raison de le préciser c'est une interventionchirurgicale qui est extrêmement bien codifié
encore une fois il y a une école francophone
de prélèvements à laquelle on participe on
forme les jeunes chirurgiens pour déjà la
technique opératoire mais aussi le savoir
être lors de cette intervention et donc c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement bien codifié
il y à une technique opératoire il y a un déroulé, qui est
donc écrit et ce n'est pas : on arrive on regarde
on prend et on part. Non c'est une intervention
chirurgicale comme une autre aujourd'hui.